avec nous maintenant pierrefitte keable
ministre de l'économie de l'innovation
du québec bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion alors on va jusqu'à 15000
dollars de pardon pourquoi 15000 on
imagine que c'est assez pour beaucoup
mais que c'est très peu pour d'autres
actes et on a regardé poèmes en a 12 mai
d'entreprise qu'on a ciblé sont affectés
par l'unfp trois régions administratives
par des fermetures complètes personnel
on aurait avait aussi pourvues bars et
restaurants les moyens des frais fixes
et on comprend que nous remboursons tous
les frais fixes sauf les files
d'attentes salariale qui elle était rayé
couverte avec ce salariat du fédéral je
pense à permettre la majorité de pouvoir
passer dans la mesure où si le
gouvernement et ce gouvernement qui
décide de fermer comme étant sa solution
dans les circonstances est ce que vous
devriez pas couvrir 100 % des coûts
fixes et couvrir beaucoup plus que
quinze mille dollars pour bien des
entreprises qui n'auront pas les mecs
qui n'auront pas à céder 15 mai dollars
vraiment vous comprendre que nous
couvrons 100% des frais fixes autre que
les salaires donc je pense que avec le
programme fédéral la chose au salariale
on y va en complémentarité mais je suis
très à l'aise avec la couverture que le
taux des frais fixes mais temps de crise
le dollar ont été les chiffres là parce
que on pensait c'est adéquat faut
oublier qu'il ya d'autres programmes qui
existent aujourd'hui prêts à vous les
liquidités disponibles pour aujourd'hui
je pense le programme nettement pour
aujourd'hui parce que les entreprises
parce qu'elle dix ans pour aujourd'hui
il pense rester ouverte elle croyait
avoir investi énormément d'argent s'être
vraiment préparer à respecter
complètement les consignes sanitaires
avec le 2 mai et toutes les modalités et
aujourd'hui on leur dit qu'on ferme
complètement alors il ya des entreprises
qui vont avoir besoin peut-être de jeu
suivant mon trente mille quarante mille
dollars mais ils ne vont recevoir que
15000 dollars de compensation de votre
part
on réagit à la santé publique les règles
sont faites par les autres encore une
fois le 12 une entreprise qui peut avoir
jusqu'à 15-20 de raout les frais fixes
qui couvre tous les frais au complet moi
je pense quand même ce programme qui est
relativement riche aujourd'hui alors je
pense qu'il faut il ya l'élection c'est
assez qu'on veut m'écouter pour
l'instant oui pour l'instant c'est
suffisant cela dit sur les quoi vous
avez dit 25 mille entreprises qui
connaissent de grandes difficultés
présentement est ce que vous nous dites
dans le fond et qu'il faut accepter
jusqu'à un certain point qui est
quelques milliers de ces entreprises qui
vont faire faillite ou qui vont devoir
fermer
il faut pas mélanger les choses ici on
reparle parlons de ce qui reste est
aujourd'hui on parle 12 mai l'entreprise
on donne je suis à 15 dollars par
entreprise trouver leurs frais fixes
donc je pense que maintenance de
programmes que je considère adéquat dans
les circonstances on parle de d'autres
pme qui souffre la relance économique
qui va être plus tard 10 dans certaines
régions la sorte d'accord pour l'instant
nous avons quand même des programmes de
trait on est la seule province en
passant qui a plus de 1.6 milliard de
disponibilité mais tant que tu es trouve
donc on est très c'est un programme très
important je prends soin pour minimiser
sa deuxièmement on travaille avec le
programme de loyer vous rappelez
peut-être que le programme des deux
loyers du fédéral nous étions la seule
province qui accordait un pourcentage
pour permettre aux propriétaires de
cliquer bon seulement 23 mille
locataires ont profité du programme le
fédéral est temps de revoir le programme
ordre et avec eux pour le bonifier la
mouche pense qu'ils aient beaucoup de
femmes qui sont faits par le
gouvernement du québec pour s'assurer
que les 25 30 mille pme l'eau à
l'extérieur du cas de la zone rouge
qu'ils ont des pressions de la
difficulté on fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour les aider je pense qu'entre le
salaire qui va être subventionnés et on
espère un programme de loyer doit être
bonifié je pense la bonne approche pour
s'assurer que nos pme plus sur lui
notariaux ne ferme pas comme vous n'a
pas la même politique est aujourd'hui le
médecin hygiéniste en chef de l'ontario
le docteur david julien disait pourquoi
pénaliser des commerces qui ont beaucoup
investi pour la réouverture
si on ne peut pas prouver qu'ils sont à
la base d'éclosion majeur vous répondez
quoi ça je suis pas moi-même
qualification ou un monsieur fini en
fosse fier ou sept à dix la république
mois il s'est jugé réagi et je vous dis
aujourd'hui avec les 12 mai le commerce
section qui vont fermer en donnant
jusqu'à qu'ils ne donnera je pense que
c'est un très bon programme on parle
d'un mot on va voir ce qui va arriver la
fin octobre on espère tous que là on va
pouvoir et ouvrir l'économie vont plaire
faut pas oublier que j'allais me faire
votre programme si on devait fermer
aussi au monde avant d'acter ce que j'ai
dit en conférence de presse aujourd'hui
c'est que dépendant de la largeur des
régions infectées dépendant du nombre de
mois il faut que comme gouvernement on
s'ajuste pour s'assurer que l'écosystème
économique plus avoir une pérennité
c'est sûr on veut pas avoir une
situation où quand l'économie va
reprendre dans fin 2021 qu'une fleur une
situation inédite à compter du 14 juin
scud d'entreprises offrent aux feuilles
puis dans ma main ronge l agence
publique ont été enlevés quand même 100
millions dans disponibilité pour les
mots lecteur que je pensais beaucoup
d'argent donc 100 millions à ça ça vous
avez dit que j'ai appliqué aux usa les
entreprises mais si au moins de 9 ans il
faut fermer encore fils il faut
prolonger est ce que vous allez
continuer d'aider les entreprises
le devoir de s'assurer que l'écosystème
demeure en place je travaille
étroitement avec mes collègues de france
opposant le jugement verum suffisant
pour spéculer la pression de mouvements
par mois vous voulez bien je comprends
mais j'entends quand même les les gens
du milieu qui vont aussi plus que moi
peut-être encore davantage qu'ils sont
déçus qu'ils sont inquiets qu'ils ne
comprennent pas pourquoi c'est comme ça
qu'ils croyaient vraiment avoir fait les
bonnes choses pour respecter toutes les
demandes du gouvernement et de la santé
publique
je pense commission du panier du milieu
deux côtés ces discussions de ponelle
discussions seraient santé publique à
l'ars de toute évidence je respecte la
décision je suis solidaire avec eux
d'autre part
je me répète le gouvernement du québec
et le gouvernement qui était le plus
actif de tous les gouvernements
provinciaux pour l'aide aux entreprises
ont aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation qui est relativement bonne par
rapport à d'autres secteurs
moi je suis à l'aise il faut rester à
l'écouté et vous avez raison faut que
l'écosystème puisse avoir une pérennité
c'est le devoir du gouvernement de
s'assurer qu'on puisse faire le plus
possible les circonstances je suis
confortable
très bien merci monsieur merci de ce
fait lui aussi beaucoup